welcome to how to build the future today
our guest is Mark Zuckerberg mark you've
built one of the most influential
companies in the history of the world so
we are especially excited that you are
here I'm not sure where to go from there
um well why don't we start with just the
early days of Facebook tell us what it
was like when you started it sure so for
me the thing that I was really
fascinated by and it always have been is
people right and how people work in
artists in college I studied psychology
and computer science and you know one of
the things that you learn when you study
psychology is that there are all these
parts of the brain which are geared just
towards understanding people right
understanding language how to
communicate with each other
understanding facial expressions
emotions processing yet when I looked
out at the internet right in 2004 which
is when I was getting started you can
find almost anything else that you
wanted right you could find news movies
music reference materials but the thing
that mattered the most to people which
was other people and like understanding
what's going on with them it just wasn't
there right and I think what was going
on was that all that other content was
just out there able to be indexed by you
know search engines and and other
services but in order to understand
what's going on with people you needed
to build tools that made it so that they
could express what was going on with
themselves you know I wanted to figure
out what courses to take so I I built
this little website coursematch that you
know that just made it so you could
enter what courses you were taking and
you could click on them and see who else
was in them and it did all these
correlations who told you people who
took this course we're likely to enjoy
this course too and you know the thing
that just struck me from the beginning
is you know people would just spend
hours clicking through the here are the
courses that people are taking and Wow
like isn't it interesting that this
person is interested in these things and
it was just text right there's nothing
that was like super interesting there
but that just struck me is you know
people have this deep thirst to
understand what's going on with with
those around them and you know there
were probably you know 10 other things
like that then I built when I was at
Harvard before I actually got around to
building the first version of Facebook
that kind of added a lot of these things
together did you think Facebook was
going to be a company when you started I
built the first version of Facebook
because it's something that my friends
and I wanted to use at Harvard a
directory and a way to connect with the
other people around us and I didn't
think at all that was going to be a
company I remember very specifically the
night that that we launched the first
version I went out to to get pizza with
a couple of my friends who now work here
and you know and I remember really
clearly we were talking about how one
day we thought that someone was going to
build a community like this for the
world and that that would be some
company but like it clearly wasn't gonna
be us I mean it just it wasn't even I
didn't even occur yeah no I mean it
wasn't even an option that we considered
that it might be us I mean we just
weren't focused on building a company
back then we were just building
something that that that we thought
would be useful at our school so as you
look back is there something that made
Facebook different from the other
projects that you had built that allowed
it to turn into this the companies today
um well for one I think we we kept going
right so I mean they the others I mean
course match and you know just the the
other different crowdsource tools you
know they kind of served their purpose
yeah and then we were done worse
with Facebook there was just such you
know people loved it right and had such
an intensity of using I think within a
couple of weeks two-thirds of students
at Harvard were using it and all these
other students said MIT and other local
universities were writing in asking us
if we could open up Facebook it at their
school so we kind of just followed that
right um you know again we didn't I
didn't set out and you know my roommates
didn't set out to to build a service
that we're going to turn into a company
but we just kind of followed what people
wanted and that led us to expand it to
all these other schools and and
eventually beyond schools and to you
know at some point once we'd hired a
bunch of people we decided to turn it
into a company and and go for this
mission of connecting the world but
that's not where we started is you
think about where you did start is there
other advice that comes to mind that you
give to other people that want to build
products uh that you can take away from
the early days of Facebook yeah you know
I always think that you should start
with the problem that you're trying to
solve in the world and not start with
deciding that you want to build a
company writing the best company is that
that get built are things that are
trying to drive some kind of social
change even if it's just local in one
place I you know more than starting out
because you want to make a bunch of
money or have a lot of people working
for you or or build some company in some
way so you know I always think that this
is kind of a perverse thing about
Silicon Valley in a way through which is
that you know people decide often that
they want to start a company before they
even decide what they want to do and
that just feels really backwards to me
and you know for anyone who said the
experience of actually building a
company you know that you go through
some really hard things along the way
and I think part of what gets you
through that is believing in what you're
doing and knowing that what you're doing
is is really delivering a lot of value
for people and that's I think how the
best companies end up getting made I
want to talk for a second about low
points because I think people never
appreciate how bad they really are and I
think it's always reassuring to hear
that even Mark Zuckerberg went through
some serious low points and came out
okay so can you tell us about some of
the hardest parts in the history of the
early history of Facebook yeah I think
one of the hardest parts for me was was
actually when Yahoo offered to buy the
company for for a lot of money because
up until that point that was this
turning point in the company where
before that we every day we just come in
and kind of do what we thought was the
right next thing to do right we'd open
two more schools we we open to high
school and open beyond schools and you
know launch more photos so because
because that's what it seemed like the
next thing that we needed to do to help
people express themselves and understand
more what was going on around them but
then no yahoo came in with this with
this really meaningful offer right even
a billion dollars for
into the company I was a couple of years
Edeka right and you know we have 10
million people using the product at the
time quite so it wasn't like it wasn't
as if it were obvious that we were going
to succeed far beyond that and that was
the first point where we really had to
to look at the future and say wow is
what we're going to build I'm going to
actually be so much more meaningful for
this and you know that caused a lot of
interesting conversations in the company
and with our investors and you know at
the end of that Dustin and I just
decided you know we think that we can
actually go connect more than just the
10 million people who are in schools we
can go beyond that and have this really
be a successful thing and we decide to
go for it but it was really stressful
because a lot of people really thought
that we should sell the company and and
you know for a lot of folks who joined a
start-up I feel like at that point I
hadn't been very good about
communicating that we were trying to go
for this mission yeah you know we just
showed up every day and yeah and just
kind of did what we thought was the the
right next thing to do so for a lot of
the folks who joined early on that there
weren't really aligned with me right for
them you know they joined and um you
know being able to sell a company for a
billion dollars after a couple years was
I was like a home run right and it is a
home run right then and that's you know
I think that that's um I get that but
you know that I think that the fact that
I didn't communicate very well about
what we were trying to do cause caused
this huge tension and the part that was
painful wasn't wasn't turning down the
offer it was the fact that after that a
huge amounts of the company quit because
they didn't believe in and what we were
what we were doing right I mean if you
look at the management team that we had
did that fellow management team leave
the whole management team was gone
within within about a year after that
did you ever regret that decision in
that period like where there are times
where you were like well we should have
sold um you know we were I was I got
really lucky because you know not only
did did what I believed in end up
working out but it ended up working out
pretty quickly right so it literally you
know I think this was in the summer of
2006 and by I think the next month after
that we launched news feed or which now
ten years later looking back at it is
you know one of the
most used products in the world and then
we launched the ability for anyone to
sign up which immediately started
growing the community so within a few
months after turning down the offer I
think it was actually pretty clear that
that was the right decision but you know
I think you know since then there have
been much harder decisions that we've
had to make where you know sometimes you
have to you have to bet on something and
and you know either
you know bet the direction of the
company or you know bet billions of
dollars on something it's not going to
be clear with your right for five or ten
years and you know that I think actually
can end up being much harder than this
what I want to talk about next but
before we go there have you ever thought
about selling the company again since no
after that poor name is just yeah got
that out of the way we're gonna be here
for a long time and yeah cool um yes so
I want to talk about one of the most
common questions we get from people
building products is how to decide what
to build how to figure out when to bet
the company how to do something totally
new yeah and I think one thing that
Facebook is done incredibly well is
figure out what to build and beep and
build this repeated innovation culture
which i think is like the hardest thing
to do in business so how have you done
that and how do you advise other people
to do the same I think the key is
building a company which is focused on
learning as quickly as possible
right companies are learning organisms
and you can make decisions that either
make it's that you learned faster or you
learn slower and you know in a lot of
ways building a company is like
following the scientific method right
you try a bunch of different hypotheses
and if you set up the experiments well
then you kind of learn what to do and
that's that's an important philosophy so
there are all these different decisions
that we make inside the company you know
everything down to really empowering
individual engineers we invest in this
huge testing framework right at any
given point in time there aren't there's
not just one version of Facebook running
in the world right there's probably tens
of thousands of versions running because
engineers here have the power to to try
out idea and and ship it to you know
maybe 10,000 people or a hundred
thousand people and then they get a
readout on how
that version of what they did whether it
was a change to show better content a
newsfeed or UI change or some new
feature they could have read out on how
that version performed compared to the
baseline version of Facebook that we
have on everything that we care about
how how connected people are you know
how much people are sharing and how much
they say that they're finding meaningful
content business metrics like how much
revenue we make and engagement of the
overall community and you know by
running in tens of thousands of
different experiments inputting the
power in people's hands to try all these
different things you can imagine we just
make so much more progress that we could
if every change had to be approved by me
right already every idea had to come
from for management so I do think
there's something very deep about
building this you know learning culture
and moving quickly towards that that
just helps you get ahead over time what
about the the bigger bets like making a
large acquisition or the rollout of a
news feed or something like that how do
you edit those decisions work so I
actually think when you do stuff well
you don't you you shouldn't have to do
big crazy things right so you want to
actually evolve in a way where you're
working with your community and making
steps and learning so take newsfeed for
example that there was a relatively big
shift but it actually had been a couple
of years in the making by watching what
how people were using the service right
so know it when we started off we didn't
have anything like news feed that showed
you updates from from what people were
sharing we just had profiles and what we
found were originally one of the big
behaviors was people just click around
right - they'd click on different
profiles you know hundreds of them just
- and they'd go through all their
friends to see what people had changed
right to see what the update was and and
in in their friends day and we learned
from that that people were not just
interested in looking up and learning
about a person but also understanding
the day-to-day changes so you know first
we made this product that I just showed
in order which of your friends had
updated their profile right so that at
least told you whose profile to click on
and then you know the first version
reduced food was really simple all it
did was it basically took the content
that people were posting and put it in
order on on your homepage
so I think when you're when when things
are working well you use data and you
use the qualitative feedback that you're
getting from from listening to how your
community is using your product to tell
you what problems to go solve and then
you basically use intuition to figure
out what the solutions to those problems
might be and then you test those
hypotheses by rolling them out and
getting more data and feedback on that
and then that gives you a sense of where
to go um you know when I look at things
like you know we bought you know the
oculus team for a lot of money right I
actually view that as you know if we'd
done a better job of building up some of
the expertise to do some of that stuff
internally then you know maybe we
wouldn't have had to do that but you
know instead we hadn't done that and you
know the oculus team is by far the most
talented team working on that problem so
it just made sense to go make this big
move but I actually kind of think as as
CEO it's your job to not get into a
position where you need to be doing
these crazy things righted yes of course
it's inevitable you know over the period
of doing stuff you'll you know you can't
be ahead of everything so it's better to
to make big moves and be willing to do
that then you know have pride and and
not do that and never admit that you
that you could have done something
better in the past but but then when
stuff is working well you're learning
incrementally and and growing that way
speaking of growing one thing I heard
you say years ago is that one of the
best things Facebook had done was invent
the idea of a growth group oh and so
this is something now that I've heard a
lot of founders ask about could you tell
us is that still something you recommend
people running companies put in place
and how Facebook's worked in the early
days so making it so we could grow
faster was I think the most important
product feature that we ended up
building for Facebook and you know the
traditional approach to growing and
marketing is you know you have a
communications group or you have a
marketing team and you buy ads and yeah
you know I think there's some sometimes
there's a place for it for that
especially when you're trying to
communicate something and get a message
out but if you're actually trying to to
grow a product I think the often the
best levers for doing that are within
the product themselves and getting
people in your community who enjoy what
you're doing to evangelize that to their
friends and getting that to happen
efficiently as if
as possible so there's no magic in the
growth group that we that we built that
other people can't replicate you know
it's it's just being very rigorous with
data investing in data infrastructure so
that way you can process all these
different experiments and learn what
people are trying to tell you and and
then go invest engineering and actually
trying to grow the community cuz I think
that's the most important feature for a
lot of networks and can you tell how
much of an impact that group had on the
growth rate of Facebook um yeah I think
it's you know their overall I think it's
been very big I don't have a number off
the top my head but I've been even just
looking at your just some of these
specific features that we've built like
people you may know right which is yeah
you know one of the important things
right again if you're you know social
product isn't that useful if you're not
connected to other people you want in
your using it so you know helping you go
from signing up for Facebook to
connecting to the people that you care
about most is probably one of the most
important things that we can do another
thing that I think Facebook is done
exceptionally well is hiring and and I
always tell founders that this is the
thing you have to get good at so how
have you hired your team and what do you
look for when you bring people on if you
think about it you know I started the
company one has 19 right so I can't
institutionally believe that experience
is that important right or else I would
have a hard time reconciling to myself
right and and and the company so you
know we invest in in people who we think
are just really talented even if they
haven't done that thing before and you
know that applies to people who are
fresh out of university as well as you
know people like you know the CFO who
took the company public and not taking a
company public before right and hit a
lot of his background was in you know
production development to Genentech
before so you know just focus on really
talented people and so if you don't have
the experience to look for how do you
assess someone's raw talent um
well often you can tell from different
things that they've done right so it's
it's not that you know obviously
everyone's done something right if even
if you're 19 right you've um you've done
side projects and interesting stuff
and you know I think what's important is
not to believe that someone has to have
specifically done the job that they're
going to do in order to be able to to do
it well one of the things that I think
we've done well is is just given the
people at the company a lot of
opportunity right so you know it's not
just me who started when I was 19 and
and now you know I'm running this big
company there were a number of people
who joined who were you know people I
did problem sets with at Harvard or they
dropped out of Stanford or you know
different programs who have grown with
the company over this long period of
time and you know one of the things that
I'm the most proud of is we have about
12 different product groups of the
company and all of the people who are
running them with the exception of one I
did not join the company running a
product group or reporting to me that's
amazing um and the one exception was is
David Marcus who was the CEO of a fifty
billion dollar public company so you
know some pretty happy that that he's on
board and having him run a product group
I think is a pretty big coup too but
literally none of them started off
reporting to me
you know they all start off in different
different roles some where engineers
some where data analysts some where
product managers and they've all grown
but I think what happens is you know
people see that you create opportunities
for people and and that also I think
keeps the best people engaged and makes
the best people want to come work at
your company because they feel like oh
I'm going to get those kind of
opportunities - cool yeah what are you
most excited about over the next 20
years what do you think will be the
major transformations how will Facebook
transform how do you think the rest of
the world to transform so we have this
ten-year roadmap I was great you know
three of the the big changes that we
want to see in the world and we're
focused on three things
connectivity rights are getting everyone
in the world on the Internet
right now more than you know more than
half the world is not on the Internet
which is you know I think a lot of
people in Silicon Valley quite take this
for granted right the internet because
it you know it's it just is not
uniformly available and if we want to
solve a lot of the the big challenges of
the world today they're not problems
that any one group of people or even one
country can solve right they they really
involve coming together and giving
everyone an opportunity to participate
and solving them so I think connecting
everyone is is really a key
which is going to be be great for for
people around the world the next one is
AI I think that that's just gonna unlock
so much potential in so many different
domains and we use it at Facebook for a
lot of different things for showing
people content that they're going to
find more meaningful for making sure
that you connect with the people you
actually care about on the service but
in a lot of ways the work that we're
doing on AI to push the fundamental you
know state of the art forward is exactly
the same stuff that's going into systems
that diagnose diseases better right or
find better drugs to treat people or
that you know other companies are using
when they build self-driving cars and
you know these are things they're going
to save lives right I mean if you can I
heard this story recently that at this
conference where someone has built a
machine learning application where you
can take a picture of a lesion on
someone's skin and it can detect
instantly whether it's skin cancer with
the accuracy of the best dermatologists
and doctors in the world so you know I
mean who doesn't want that right now
like you're gonna build to put the power
in your doctors hand to become the best
doctor of the world at that thing
everyone will be the best doctor in the
world and that's a really fundamental
thing right that you know I I get a
little bit frustrated I think when
people you know fearmonger about about
AI and how it could end up hurting
people because I think in many real ways
around diseases or not driving more
safely this is going to save people's
lives and push and push people for it so
that that's a really big deal I think
for the next ten years and then you know
the next thing that I always think is is
going to make a big difference is um you
know over 10 or 15 years there's a new
major computing platform that comes
around that allows people to do
completely different things than they
could do before right so you know 20
years ago you know most of us were using
desktop computers they were kind of
clunky you know we use them and work
because commit our work more productive
but most people didn't use them for fun
now we have phones which you know help
us connect with each other and they're
much more human devices but there's
going to be another platform after that
and I think that's going to be virtual
reality and augmented reality and that I
think is just going to help people you
know be more creative experience what
other people are feeling much more
immersively than we even can through
through video and things like that today
so I'm really excited about that trend
as well so you were nineteen when you
started Facebook one question we hear a
lot that Y Combinator is I'm 19 today I
really want to you know do whatever I
can to make the world better what should
I do
so how do you advise people who are 90
today and want to impact the world like
you have you know I always think that
the most important thing that
entrepreneurs should do is pick
something they care about work on it but
don't actually commit to turning it into
a company until it's working and I think
that if you look at the data of like the
very best companies that have gotten
built I actually think a tremendous
percent of them have been built that way
and not from people who decided upfront
that they wanted to start a company
because you just get locked into some
local minimum a lot of the time a local
maximum I totally agree and just to make
this point how far into Facebook did it
actually become a company um I don't
know
I think probably I think it became a a
formal Delaware company when Peter Thiel
invested about six months in when we
were first talking to Peter about
raising money Dustin and I were very
clear with him that we were planning on
going back to school ready Nara you know
I started Facebook own as a sophomore we
took the summer offered no classes over
the summer we were working on it and
then you know our stated game plan was
to go back to school in the fall and
continue working on it then but not like
sit sit in an office and work on it
full-time and Peter was just kind of
like alright sure you are I guess he
knew better than we think he just
believed that you weren't actually gonna
go back to high you must have I mean
you'd have to ask him but I will were
interviewing him in this series I was
very good so I I think he would probably
say that he knew that we were not going
to go back to school or believed that he
could talk us out of it but he didn't
have to it was it was pretty clear that
the amount of work was just growing so
quickly but we actually did drop out
immediately
we told Harvard that we were taking one
semester off and and then we told her
that we take another semester off and
then a year off and then after that we
kind of
we were going back uh speaking of Peter
and a sort of a closing question what's
the best piece of advice he ever gave
you I think Peter was the person who who
told me this really pithy quote that in
a world that's changing so quickly the
biggest risk you can take is not taking
any risk and I really think that that's
true right a lot of people I think think
that you know whenever it comes to
whatever you get yourself into a
position where you have to make some
some big shift in direction or do
something you know they're always people
are going to point to the downside risks
of that decision and locally there may
be right right I mean if for any given
decision that you're going to make
there's upside and downside but in
aggregate if you are stagnant and you
don't make those changes then then I
think you're guaranteed to fail right
and not not catch up so to some degree I
think it's really right that over time
the biggest risk that you can take is to
not take any risks that is a great place
to leave it thank you very much all
right